my name is Hannah Elliot and I drive
luxury cars for bloomberg pursuits for
years I've traveled the world testing
the most incredible cars on the road
we've started this new series to share
what I've learned in it I'll show you
the very best routes tell you which car
to drive and give you tips on what to do
along the way
think of it as the ultimate luxury
roadtrip experience
welcome to Bloomberg pursuits drive
to my mind the Scenic Byway along
California's highway 1 is an
unparalleled world-class driving
destination for ease of access
comfortable roads and breathtaking views
the road leading north from santa
barbara through Big Sur California just
can't be beat
naturally the car you take to Big Sur
should be as epic as the route I suggest
the 2017 rolls-royce dawn the brand new
v12 convertible that will start hitting
the streets in the fall
Don refers to the original silver dawn
that rolls-royce first made in the early
1950s only 28 were made this new dawn is
a $350,000 cruiser that is jam-packed
with luxuries like lambswool floor mats
and hand-stitched leather
it's so smooth it's just like on this
air suspension you're basically on a
cloud the steering is really nice it's
so easy to steer the steering wheel is
really thin kind of like a yacht in fact
Rolls has used yacht making techniques
by third and fourth-generation workers
for years you can see it in the lines of
the brushed wood interior it's perfectly
seamless the drive from Santa Barbara to
Carmel at the northern tip of Big Sur
will take you through 220 miles of rocky
outcroppings crashing waves sandy
beaches and Green Meadows make a first
stop at morro rock about two hours north
of santa barbara get out and take a late
morning stroll along the shoreline
enjoying the salty air
you should make dinner plans for the end
of your drive
I recommend the post ranch in the
famously exclusive cliffside restaurant
and resort where room sometimes must be
booked a year in advance with that
delicious meal ahead of you enjoy the
smells of the flowers and the ocean
breezes while continuing north on
highway 1 if you are lucky you may catch
a glimpse of whales breaching off in the
distance
like Big Sur itself the exterior of the
Don has a little bit of everything it's
soft around the corners and along the
sides and it looks a little flattened
overall but the LED headlights and newly
redesigned grille give it some edge the
Don's 8-speed automatic transmission is
perfect it works with the powerful
engine like butter on toast it will hug
the gentle curves of the two-lane
highway and brake tightly when you want
to stop and enjoy a view
the overall effect is one of lumbering
ease slow down friend it seems to say
life is meant to be enjoyed
stop and see the sights
and the sights should include a brief
sojourn at 5-4 state park it's a
thousand acres nestled on the western
slope of the Santa Lucia Mountains and
it makes for an amazing vantage point as
evening approaches everything will
become quiet with your eyes closed you
wouldn't even know you were in a
convertible you'll roll into Big Sur in
the evening just as the sun's rays give
the rocks and sea a heavenly blood and
the mystic post ranch and completes the
magical setting
the service and the beautiful grounds
and every part of the post ranch attend
is perfectly matched by the
craftsmanship and the attention to
detail in a Rolls Royce
so get the car take the drive stay at
post ranch you won't want to leave